Before this video begins
It's time for me to flex on you kids.
That's right, I have the new Honor 8X
Very nice
Very good
I love the look and feel of this phone
It feels very
P r e m i u m
Very minimalistic, aesthetic design
I really like it, it's very cool.
Look at that, look at that shine
Wow lookit
Honestly, look at that
If that's not epic-ly, I don't know what it is
It has great value and low pricing
It's very impressive what they pulled off with this phone.
It has a very big display
6.5 inch with 91% screen to body ratio
So, it's big
It's very big
It also has this AI camera, highly intelligent
So if I point it at something, it will change the settings to what it's looking at
So now, it's looking at 9-year olds
And, if I do this, it notices it's a face
and it changed to portrait
So, you can take really professional photos with it
Because of that, I've taken some really cool photos with it
I love it, and uh, yeah
If you guys are interested in it, check out the link in the description
for more information from the Honor official forums
or
and
You can also win one, if you check out the link, so do that
Enjoy the video! Back to Pewds from the future
Q&A Time!
[clap] [clap] [clap] [clap]
Q&A Time! やったですね
Woohoo! Yea!
[ Music ]
Welcome to Q&A, the thing that Youtubers do when they're completely out of ideas
of what they're gonna make
It's literally the bottom of the barrel
of whatever content you can make
That's right, worse than 'You Laugh You Lose'
Now for real I haven't done a Q&A in uhh
When was the last time? Honestly -
3 years ago?
[pewds laughing]
So I asked on Twitter: "hey ask me stuff"
and I will answer. So here we go
"How the frick do you manage-"
Thank you for censoring. I appreciate it
"To upload a video daily? I mean I literally watch you everyday so..."
"...I guess it's bros like me who encourage this madness."
I really enjoy it. It's uhh
It's fun to have a goal
For, set for you everyday
Today, I'm gonna make a video
No matter what
No matter what happens, you know
Things happen, undoubtedly
But I always have that goal, I'm gonna get a video done
And that keeps me, it keeps me on my toes, It keeps me interested
That's the long answer, the short answer
I have editors
"Where the frick, did Michael the romanian go?"
Back to Romania
Where he belongs
"How were you able to portray a real-" oh, wow, really deep question here, guys.
"...a realistic version of yourself on Youtube..."
"...a website which seems to reward individuals who portray a completely different version of themselves..."
"...than reality? and what gave you the confidence to continue to do instead of giving in?"
Um...
(hits table)
(spanks the table)
I don't think it's in- until recently
where I fully unbraced
just being as honest as I can be on YouTube
And I think eh, you are right and wrong
I guess- here's the thing, people are smarter than you think
People have noticed I think, that I have been trying to be
more honest in my videos and open about who I am
And what I'm actually thinking
And, that has just been welcome with open arms
I think people really do appreciate honesty
It's the kinda' thing that I'm driven towards
With other YouTubers as well
I wanna' watch people who I think are
a- authentic, and real, and not just some version of
what they think their audience wants to see
"Do you have anything to say after Ethan..." *giggles*
"...accused you of throwing him under the bus..."
"...on the whole BetterHelp thing?"
I REPLIED LAST VIDEO
Just cuz' everyone is asking so much about this
I-it always seems like there's some uh -
fan drama between me and Ethan
but uh... between us personally,
Uh, there's no bad blood.
Yea.
"When will you stop stealing my videos?"
When will you stop stealing mine?
Any day I upload a video this
[buzzer noise]
"Where do you see yourself and Youtube in ten years?"
c l a p  c l a p
Well hopefully I'm in Japan.
Other than - I don't know.
"Do you think you'll be doing Youtube your whole life?"
HOW WOULD I KNOW?!
Do you think you'd do anything your whole life?
stahp asking me these deep questions :c
I remember like, six years ago,
I thought; "Okay, maybe if I'm lucky,
- I can do another year,
or maybe two years of Youtube."
The lifespan of a Youtuber -
a few years ago -
was so...
quick.
Most early Youtubers,
They're not making videos anymore.
That's just the case.
So, I was constantly following the
path of other Youtubers, before I
was er... where I am today.
But know I kinda have to set my own path
and it's been going well so far...
I'm happy that I'm still able to make videos.
I don't know.
"Book literature club -
w h e n ?"
#AskPewd.
Um...
hEh hEh
I'M SORRY
I know I haven't been doing book review
[cLap cLAp]
I-I've been reading a ton though...
I've been reading just as much as I would normally do so-
It's not like I haven't done that so I can't make them
it's more the fact that I felt like
the videos were a little bit-
It was just me summarizing the video
*He meant book*
'cause that's all I had time for
I didn't really have time to dwell any deeper with any...
any of the books
at least some of them I did
It just felt very shallow and it just felt like:
"No one's reading these books anyway,"
"What's the point? I'm just spoiling the plot for everyone"
It just felt stupid. I felt...
like, uhhh, who cares?
I wanna figure out a better format where...
it can be more engaging with you guys
'cause I do want more people to join in
and actually join on the literature club
I think that could make it way more interesting and...
I need to figure out a way to do that
So that's why I haven't been doing it
But then again maybe that's what people want
Maybe people just want me to...
talk about books
I don't know
"What's the meaning of life?"
DEEP QUESTIONS
To rid yourself from all the suffering
oh yeah
"Is scare PewDiePie season 2 coming or no?"
Probably not
probably not, most likely not
I kind of given up on trying to push for it
The thing is I had a... it was a nightmare to record but I still have so many great memories from it
I'm still glad I had those, y'know
"Are you going to make more videos with Jack and Mark in the future? When?"
We did that one video together, which was really popular
uhhhhh
If we get a chance to, I'm down
"Why is this little break so d*mn long?"
When was that?
*Cackle*
Is that me playing Metal Gear Sol-
AHHHH
STOP-
stop holding me accountable!
I'm really bad, Marzia can agree
she- she would- if she's watching she's nodding her head right now
'cause if I stop doing something for a while, even if I enjoyed it,
I don't want to go back into it
Whenever me and Marzia watch TV shows and we haven't watched one in a while
I'm like "ehhh, that show sucked"
and she's always like "NO, you really enjoyed it!"
and I was like "ehhh... naw I didn't" *pew laughs*
"Are you going to cross the bridge again?"
Jesus Christ
N- Yes, okay, you gotta face your fears
You gotta man up, and get back on that horse
So yes, I will cross the bridge again
Yes, I will b- beat the horse
whatever.. the expression is
"How do you find cool clothing brands? Ask Marzia too plz."
Well, Marzia isn't here
Just- just look online, there's so much great stuff online, so many great websites
I'm looking at clothing almost every single day
It's just something I enjoy now
It's really weird, I never thought I would say that
"Will the book club ever come back?"
YES IT WILL
Give me suggestions
Give me ideas of what I can do to make it more interactive
I was thinking maybe I should do a subreddit or something like that so I can actually get your comments about it
Uh, maybe some video responses, I don't know
"Who will be the best man at your wedding?"
I DON'T KNOOOOOW
Edgar
This is a great Q&A
I DON'T KNO- *pew laughs*
"What was your favourite game when you were a kid?"
*This doesn't match the tweet???*
'Star Fox 64'
It depends how young I am, it's kind of in stages
When I was really young; 'Pokémon Blue'
When I was younger than that, it was like 'Donkey Kong Country'
and after that... it's probably like 'World of Warcraft' or 'Star Fox 64'
oh my God yeah, that game was amazing
Just discovering the new paths...
it blew my mind
Then I got into MMOs, I played so much 'Tibia' and so much 'World of Warcraft'
"Hi Felix, what kind of music do you listen to?"
I've been listening non-stop
??????Drain Gang?????
*I have no idea what he said*